[Music]
thank you very much
Hello everyone
from the program
[Music]
important program
especially
system
[Music]
security system
on
[Music]
[Music
] development
[Music]
and more broadly
French
[Music]
in terms of application and of the sky which
are expected
it is it is
[Music]
actually
built
[Music]
program in the program for
partner
[  Music]
[Music]
today and
this day and I'm delighted too
[Music]
Hello everyone and participants
the opportunity to meet
Julien I come to someone
[Music
] as President I would like to say a
few words about the IRTS
go back to the history of my
collaboration in this first edition
of the forum
[Music]
various and complementary today
with my partners
concentrate  trer in advanced markets and
technologies
Saint-Exupéry is an IRT in the
aeronautics and space sector
[Music]
stop the 150 members and
380 collaborators
in Toulouse Bordeaux
and in Canada
based on 12 for children
NRJ NRJ
NRJ high density of
metallic materials  and
composite materials
message
activity connectivity
can we
close for example disseminate
6 aisle of techniques
and process defects
a budget of
6.6 million euros per year
42 members in 15 laboratories and 8
doctoral and post-doctoral students i  hope
among the activities I would like
to highlight some highlights
around Lia for the items
the project
and our Sophia Antipolis teams
at the end of last year carried out a
first
[Music]
we thus had the feasibility demonstrated
on a circuit
[Music]
this success
after an in-orbit update
and of course
the first cornerstone of our
artificial intelligence activities
in 2018
Quebec
[Music]
IRT Saint-Exupéry
naturally
[Music]
the project was built
in 2018
[Music]
since 2018 for a Frenchman how many
days
the Franco-Quebec project he commits
nearly 30,000 € on the subject  of the
criticism of results of very high
scientific level
31 international publications to
date
the projectile and the foundations of a
collaboration
after a
successful collaboration with the partner
[Music]
IRT Saint-Exupéry to bring the
first scientific bricks  and
technology of the project
[Music]
energy and today a reality in
addition to the first technical results
from the end of the
plateau Toulouse
[Music]
we are now fully
committed to our collaboration with
industrial partners of the
forum opens the way to multiple
works  who will participate in the
devil's hand for the transport of tomorrow
[Music]
[Applause]
proposes to continue
[Music]
Hello everyone
hello dear Nadia hello
all
so
[Music]
I will have 20 things and you
told me my dreams
really do you take it not
bad as identify
to
need
[Music]
concretely in Toulouse you have
continental
vehicle connect
[Music]
that
good indeed to be at the heart of the
reactor to be able to allow us
to finally operate this mutation this
revolution of artificial intelligence
so I train several
[Music]
a 17-year-old trying to
think about his future someone who
would like to do artificial intelligence
I'm not sure he'll
choose Toulouse from English to come and
study because we are
then even  that we have a
shônen
[Music] situation
to actually allow us to be
operating as an old really essential
of this research of this
training development so there are training
[Music]
at the industrial level at the level of
something that will happen in 30 years
and that will
[Music]
could also be there something
that we do lost in time since we
will really need
also
I wish you a very good very good I
'm really
[Music]
[Applause]
Madame Nadia
Europe
[Music]
of 6 million people is
the most successful place in  the
research intensity of France
[Music]
the acts of the pandemic
[Music
] first because in companies
[Music]
on the importance of the different Sion
[Music  ]
[Music]
all at once
that will allow us to be in the race
[Music
] first because I'm not a
7-year-old customer
[Music]
[Music  ]
we are not the place of Brest
the actors in the performance
[Music]
it is necessary for that  a
we have decided to
focus on three areas
[Music]
and from
camille
[Music]
there is a third on the subject of
training
[Music]
in the
deposit
on the question of confidence in
of course
and on the question of sovereignty
it seems important to us to be inability to
develop tools in progress
[Music]
is that
[Music  ]
[Music]
[Applause]
give the full name
[Music]
can you tell me,
obviously there is still
[Music]
it's a very special program in
the Samsung
[Music]
an international competition for
investments
[Music]
we will have confidence but behind
it is economic competitiveness
not to have confidence
[Music]
the  trust is also expected by
all  users the citizens
[Music]
[Applause]
president
my brother
today
always to say and I will
[Music]
[Music  ]
technological research program
[Music]
the opposite of
technological research research
[Music]
excellence
[Music  ]
international swimsuit
[Music]
Google Play Store
fusional
[Music]
[Music  ]
mobility systems mail also
on safety industry
sustainability
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music
] how good
already
[Music]
the results of the
what a month  the impact of character
[Music]
formation
I think it's playing now
[Music]
I think it's today
now
[Music]
2 will be structured
you
show me
[Music]
transformation
thanks again
[Music]
[Applause]